There's nothing worse.
There's nothing worse than being
pitched something that you just can't
see. You can't see it.
By the way, if you have not heard me
tell, you've not heard me tell this story,
I will tell it again.
I've told it a thousand times.
I had the opportunity to invest in
Uber. Me too, in the early stages.
Okay, listen, Mark.
I'm gonna one up you on this one.
Go ahead.
This makes me so mad.
Go ahead. Shouts out to Troy Carter.
Troy Carter tells me he's like, Kev,
there's this thing, man.
It's called Uber.
You got to invest in it.
Listen, it's easy to understand, right?
It's basically like strangers giving,
like, people they don't know rides,
like people can call on other people
for rides. I was like, what?
He was like, people can just-- There's
an app and you say you need a ride and
whoever's close to you that is like one
of the drivers under our app will come
get you. I was like, Sounds like
murderville to me.
He's like, he's like, No, man, it's
over. Trust me, man.
They're going to have like, different
tiers to it. You go, I said, This guy
has to be the stupidest shit I ever
heard. You want me to give you money to
be like, because you're telling me
that, first of all, you asked me to
pick somebody up. I'm gonna go. I don't
know that person. I ain't picking them
up. Get the f*** out.
I thought about Airbnb like Kev.
Like, stop. You're not listening to me.
It's the next thing like, this is how
we're going to make people engage with
people. We're connected.
Wait, So hold that thought.
Okay? The guy who started it.
Travis. Right. Travis.
Travis. He had a company before that.
Okay. Red swoosh.
Okay. Peer to peer networking thing.
I invested in it. I basically saved
him. Okay? Because he was running out
of money. His investors came, came to
me. I'm like, okay, you sold it.
We made a little bit of money.
He comes to me like, first off, I got
this thing. It's going to replace Taxi
Cab. It was called Uber Cab at the
time. I still got the emails, right?
I'm like, I love it.
I love it, I love it, I love it.
But yeah, the valuation then of like
10 million dollars and I said, I'll do
it at $5 million valuation for Uber
never came back to me.
He got somebody else.
So don't feel.
Bad. Whoops.
I think I think Troy may have asked me
for 50,000 to 75,000 and that would
have been, you know, 100.
Just think if I would have given him--
250 grand on a
5 million or $10 million valuation, it'd
be billions.
I mean, I've done.
Okay, okay.
But still.
It was like, oh, and he would just kill
me on it too, because what I said to
him was, I like the idea, but you're
going to have to because he I saw his
budget and everything. I'm like, you're
going to have to spend a lot more on
marketing and dealing with all the
taxicab commissions that are going to
try to put you out of business.
And so that's the challenge that I see
for you guys. And he was like, You're
right, I never heard back.
And then later on, boom.
Boom.
Yeah, it could be worse.
It could be my stupid ass, 50, 75
grand. Until this day.
I think about it. Until this f***ing
day. You know, I kind of.
I kind of avoid seeing Troy Carter,
too. Yeah.
Every time I hear Troy is in his rolls.
Troy. Troy, look at me.
And I know Troy. Troy going.
Oh.
Yeah, we had Troy on Shark Tank.
Troy is amazing.
I love Troy. Shout out to Travis, too.
Yeah. An amazing circle.
An amazing community.